sie haben ihr ziel erreicht beim impfen
zumindest 30 millionen impfungen das hat
die regierung als ziel marke vorgegeben
bis ende des jahres nachdem das boostern
ja zu spät und zu langsam in die gänge
gekommen ist ja aber jetzt schon fast
geschafft 30 millionen impfungen kurz
vor silvester ist diese zahl also
geknackt
muss dann nach der weihnachtsgans für
zehntausende zusätzlich zum festessen
und kirchenbesuch auf dem programm der
besuch im nächstgelegenen im zentrum für
bundeskanzler scholz ein schöner triumph
erhält damit das booster versprechen
seiner neuen regierung von dem zeitpunkt
an wo die impfung aller erwachsenen
möglich gewesen ist auch tatsächlich 30
millionen impfung zu erreichen e booster
kampagne ist aus sicht vieler experten
der schlüssel im kampf gegen das virus
sicher ist die fünfte welle kommt fragt
sich nur wie gewaltig
[Musik]
und jetzt gucken wir noch mal ein
bisschen genauer hinter die zahlen und
dann muss ich dann doch ein bisschen
wasser in den wein gießen denn ganz so
rund lief es dann doch nicht über die
festtage mit dem impfen da wollte man ja
genau mit demselben tempo weitermachen
wie vorher aber es gab gleich mal so
rund 30.000 impfungen pro tag über die
festtage und die 80 prozent impfquote
erste impfung die hat man nicht erreicht
das sollen jetzt im januar folgen also
das wasser in den wein jetzt wie sieht
es aus bei den neuinfektionen aktuell in
deutschland
da sehen wir kleinere balken als zuletzt
das sind die aktuellsten zahlen gerade
reingekommen knapp 14.000 neuinfektionen
in deutschland aber auch hier wasser in
den wein denn stimmen diese zahlen
überhaupt das robert koch institut weist
es nicht ganz genau es gab wieder
verzögerte meldungen über die tage also
man weiß nicht ob das die wahren zahlen
sind und vor allen dingen wurde weniger
getestet ja über die weihnachtsfeiertage
also gucken wir uns mal die wahren
zahlen an nämlich das ist die richtige
währung der blick in die krankenhäuser
wie sieht es aktuell aus die
hospitalisierung des instituts ist ja
das entscheidende und da sehen wir
mittlerweile in westdeutschland ja vor
allen dingen eine grüne karte das heißt
da ist die hospitalisierung instanz
meistens unter die drei wieder runter
gerutscht und dann sehen wir hier noch
einen hotspot thüringen nach wie vor mit
einer hospitalisierung since it ends von
deutlich über 10 also hier ist die lage
in den krankenhäusern nach wie vor
angespannt im westdeutschland hingegen
hat sich die lage etwas entspannt auch
wegen dieser booster impfung das wollen
wir jetzt fragen den virologen klaus
stört der uns zugeschaltet ist herzlich
willkommen bei bild live feste
ist das dass wir hier auf dieser karte
ist schon wieder ja in westdeutschland
grüne felder sehen bei der
hospitalisierung ist incidents ein
effekt von 30 millionen impfungen
die 30 millionen pfund machen hier schon
einen unterschied das ist überhaupt
natürlich ungleich aber die die
infektion hat natürlich auf hoher ebene
stattgefunden die letzten wochen die
zuschauer werden sich erinnern wollen
wir an institutionen in einigen
bundesländer für die über 500 600.000
gewesen so was hält eine ein virus nicht
durch irgendwann gibt es dann keine
empfängliche menschen mehr ideen ja auch
auf der kogge die relativ steil abfällt
das hier einfach keine möglichkeit mehr
bestand dass das virus nach laufen
konnte also ist eine kombination aus
laufender ins auslaufenden virus pik und
natürlich in bekämpfungsmaßnahmen unter
der booster maxxx jetzt natürlich noch
mal jetzt kann man so ein bisschen
durchatmen gerade nach weihnachten gibt
es ein bisschen gute nachrichten
offenbar von der zahlenfront und
gleichzeitig gibt es diese massive
warnung vor mikro wie schlimm wird das
denn jetzt kommt diese omikron wand von
der immer die rede ist zerstört wir
konnten kommt auf jeden fall nicht das
ist jetzt glaube ich nicht mal
diskutiert aber was man vergisst in der
berichterstattung ist dass mit jedem
nikon fall wird ja noch ein delta fall
wegfallen also wenn jetzt 50 60 prozent
der fälle tatsächlich durch viren
verursachten 50 und 60 prozent der fälle
und delta verursacht ja offensichtlich
schwerere verläufe als nicole aber hat
eine höchst wahrscheinlich die geringere
übertragungsfähigkeit also hier muss man
auch die relationen dann bewahren und
schauen sie mal wenn man sich die zahlen
anschaut die die gerade gezeigt haben
die der inzidenz war ja doppelt so hoch
wie der im winter gleichzeitig weil sie
nicht gezeigt haben was in diesen zahlen
haben wir sicherlich auch ist die anzahl
der personen die auf den
intensivstationen liegen vergleichbar
mit der in der winter werde im letzten
ja das heißt wir haben doppelt so viele
personen die
infiziert sind die positiv sind aber
viele sind asymptomatisch krank und die
gleiche anzahl auf den intensivstationen
also das ist zeigt schon wie wie
unterschiedlich die welt laufen und ist
zeigt auch ein problem was jetzt sehr
schnell zu lösen ist nämlich der
übergang von der pandemie zur mtg muss
auf definierte also welche parameter
welche indikatoren wird man sich
anschauen um langsam zur normalität
zurück bekommen in südafrika wird man
jetzt mit kontakt beschränkungen auf und
garantieren ja das ist mir ali anhand
der stört glauben sie dass das genauso
bei uns kommen wird also das heißt man
muss gar nicht mehr in quarantäne wenn
man es mit einem i konn fall zu tun
gehabt hat also man kann ja mit ihm fast
nichts garantiert auch das garantiere
ich ihnen persönlich das wird kommen
denn irgendwann ist es ja so dass die
normalität ein ziel das hat die anlagen
sind entweder infizierter
immunisiert mehrmals dann dann muss man
die im grenzwert in schwelm als
festlegen wo wir zum normalität
zurückkommen das jetzt tun wir können
nicht so lange warten wir jetzt ist ja
noch keine entscheidung gefallen wie man
die serologische untersuchung der
genesenen auch bewertet ja es gibt
ungefähr 18 12 millionen genesene die
jetzt
denselben status haben müssten wir noch
besser und schade dass geimpfte auch das
muss man erklären und wie lange wird man
quasi jeden kontakt beschenken aufrecht
erhalten welche indikatoren und
parameter möchte man wohl wenn um sagst
du messen und wann wird man zur
normalität wollt ihr das alles das kann
man jetzt berechnen moderieren und auch
dann auch der bevölkerung mit einer das
hier ist ein tolles ziel was meiner
alten also da muss ich noch mal
nachfragen weil das ja eigentlich nach
der ganz gute nachricht bei all den ja
immer noch so hohen zahlen klingt
omikron sorgt nach all dem was wir
bisher wissen für im durchschnitt
geringere oder weniger schlimme verläufe
und mit omikron könnte dann die
normalität in unser leben zurück kommen
mehr stört ja also nie konnte ich die
variante die höchstwahrscheinlich in die
in delhi überführt danach kommt eine
neue das kann ich ihnen garantieren die
wird genauso wie nikon und delta und
alter und wetter vorher sich langsam an
den menschen anpassen das sehen war er
jetzt schon die übertragungsrate in dem
zu die inkubationszeit wird auch langsam
kürzer die hat sich reduziert
findet jetzt eben schon
konkurrierenden in de mission koo oder
wären da die inkubationszeit bei zwei
bis fünf tagen nähern bei uns die
übertragungsrate steigt auch das ist
eine anpassung an den menschen also es
geht eigentlich alles in die richtige
richtung richtung n tv aber jetzt ist
natürlich noch winter infektionsdruck
ist sehr hoch ohne frage werden sich
alle die jetzt noch nicht immunisiert
oder infiziert sind auch das virus holen
höchstwahrscheinlich
schon in diesem winter viele natürlich
auch erst im sommer oder im nächsten
winter aber damit kann man jetzt dem
infektionsdruck sicherlich reduzieren
was man eben weiter booster die leute
die noch nicht die überhaupt haben
vielleicht auch noch erreicht und
kontakt beschränkung wird es auch noch
weiterhin geben um mich an wird zur
neuen welle führen aber auch bitte
dieser großen diskrepanz zwischen sehr
vielen thematischen film weniger leuten
auf intensivstationen und die todesfälle
haben sich jetzt halbiert im vergleich
zum letzten jahr danke an den biologen
klaus stöhr der uns gute und schlechte
nachricht mitbringt hochansteckende
omikron diese wand diese welle wird
kommen das ist ganz sicher aber eher
garantiert ja soweit er das kann dass
die kontakt beschränkung dann fallen
werden fallen müssen denn sonst ist das
ja alles gar nicht mehr aufrecht zu
erhalten sagt der virologe klaus stört
danke dafür ich bin glücklich dass ich
ja und bei uns im studio ist jetzt unser
bild meinung chef philippe piatti da
können wir ja schon fast sagen danke
omikron dass es dich gibt oder dass du
delta ablöst wie siehst du es also so
weit würde ich noch nicht gehen da die
übertragbarkeit von omikron ja deutlich
höher sein soll aber natürlich ist das
eine gute nachricht das hat auch
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach mir
erst vor einigen tagen gesagt dass
omikron offenbar zu deutlich milderen
verläufen führt da könnten wir
tatsächlich aufatmen denn eine
übertragbare variante sondern stärker
übertragbare variante die auch noch zu
schweren verläufen führen würde das wäre
wirklich nicht so toll nun wissen wir es
umgekehrt verläuft milder und ich habe
auch von vielen bekannten jetzt gehört
die tatsächlich über weihnachten und
silvester 14 tage jetzt in quarantäne
müssen aufgrund von omikron wegen der
mutation und wenn diese quarantäne dann
wegfallen würde da besser auch für alle
ziemlich einfach dann auch alles
aufrecht wie kaiser eben auch schon
gesagt hat absolut das machen jetzt auch
mehrere länder also südafrika
beispielsweise hat jetzt die kontakt
nach verfolgungen auch die isolation von
kontaktpersonen einfach abgeschafft auch
die briten reagieren auf diese
mikrowelle die haben dort ja tatsächlich
rekord infektionszahlen und anstatt
maßnahmen zu verschärfen lockern die
gerade die quarantäne wurde dort von 10
tagen auf sieben tage reduziert dass
ganz viele menschen müssen kommt früher
frei
müssen nicht noch länger zu hause sitzen
und könnte dann auch die ich wieder
arbeiten gehen und kritische bereiche
der infrastruktur aufrechterhalten jetzt
habe ich gerade die zahlen aus den
krankenhäusern auch gesehen da gibt es
ein bisschen mut machende zahlen auch
eine ganze karte von westdeutschland die
wieder grün geworden ist jetzt habt ihr
aus gefunden viele die dort als corona
kranke geführt werden corona patienten
geführt werden sind nicht per se corolla
patienten die haben zwar carola sind
aber wegen anderer dinge im krankenhaus
ganz genau diese zahlen die
hospitalisierung werte also menschen die
mitunter wegen corona im krankenhaus
sind die wurden von bund und ländern
einfach verfälscht angegeben so hart
muss man es leider sagen
es hieß eigentlich dass nur corona
patienten gezählt werden müssen die
krone patienten sind das hat ja dann
aber die wegen corona im krankenhaus
sind fakt ist aber dass sehr viele
bundesländer auch solche patienten
gezählt haben die wegen einer ganz
anderen krankheit ins krankenhaus
eingeliefert wurden aber zufällig auch
noch positiv getestet wurden und das
problem ist dass auf diesen werten auf
dieser hospitalisierung sinti denzler
maßnahmen beruht haben das heißt die
menschen den wurde gesagt die zahlen
steigen in den krankenhäusern wegen
corona deshalb müssen wir die maßnahmen
verschärfen die menschen haben das
mitgemacht und jetzt kommt heraus da
wurde einfach alles mögliche gezählt und
die zahlen wurden künstlich aufgeblasen
die zahlen wurden überhöht dargestellt
und deswegen wurden auch die maßnahmen
immer strenger und das haben wir gestern
abgefragt bei den bundesländern die
haben uns also ganz viele erfassen diese
zahlen nicht mal was auch schon wirklich
absolut ist aber diejenigen die diese
zahlen erfassen sagen unisono wir
erzählen
als corona patienten solche menschen die
wegen corona krankenhaus sind aber auch
solche die mit gewonnen kranken da kann
man das nicht anders besser machen ja
natürlich man müsste einfach richtig
zählen das lka hat der welt am sonntag
beispielsweise gesagt eigentlich sollten
nur die patienten in diese statistik mit
einfließen bei denen auch der
krankheitsgrund corona ist das ist ja
eigentlich eine selbstverständlichkeit
aber die bundesländer scheinen das
robert koch institut offenbar falsch
verstanden zu haben zumindest sagen sie
uns das ist das was das
robert-koch-institut uns gesagt so
machen wir und dann gehen wir gerade
nach wichtige recherche von euch